[Musique]
alors filmé caucase film de dénonciation
film peut-être de revisitation de votre
propre enfance en tout cas c'est non ça
vous fait rire nous sommes heureusement
pour réponde pas aux mots maintenant
j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas né dans
une poubelle non non non je fais des
cauchemars c'est tout mais mon enfance à
toulouse mais votre enfance a été
heureuse je vous ouvrez les yeux sur ce
qui nous environne aujourd'hui non ouais
mais c'est le principe de toute
expression c'est de regarder un truc qui
nous intéresse alors je suis allé voir
votre film dans une salle dimanche après
midi tout le monde rit et dans la salle
la moyenne d'âge était de 20 25 ans et
ce qui était très étrange c'est qu'à la
sortie du film est bien les gens se
parlaient certains s'en voulait en
disant qu est ce que je suis content
d'avoir autant ri je cite et d'autres se
demandaient comment prendre votre film
parce que vous utilisez plusieurs
registres dans ce film qui est un film
que vous voulez dérangeant ou qui est
plus grave qu'il n'y paraît
techniquement ce qu'on voulait c'était
traiter un drame humain par des moyens
burlesque et comique donc c'est assez
basique comme comme gamberge des gens
comme chaplin ont fait ça a
magnifiquement dans le passé puis y ait
des gens comme lui aussi qu'on fait ça
très bien
donc ma petite petite tentative était
dans cet esprit là car vous êtes non
seulement scénariste metteur en scène
même si l'acteur principal
bernie donc qui est à la recherche de
ses origines qui a essayé vainement de
savoir qui il était et qui étaient ses
parents et qu'il a fait un véritable
braquage sur la dass pour pouvoir enfin
obtenir son dossier
alors les registres sont différents dans
ce film c'est peut-être bien d'ailleurs
de déstabiliser le spectateur qui est
habitué à voir finalement du tout fait
du tout fabriquer du tout du tout ficelé
et d'être dans un seul registre
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
basiques de réalité sociale j'ai pas
l'impression vous voulez dénoncer la
société dans laquelle
nous vivons et en même temps il ya un
humour corrosif un peu à la charlie
hebdo d'il ya vingt ans c'est quand même
pas un film innocent comment dire ces
référents charlier de tout ça s'annonce
annoncé ça n'en est pas pour moi donc
c'est difficile de les relever mais
c'est traiter avec comment dire la
souffrance de ce garçon est énorme
donc pour la compenser il faut un
folklore qui est énorme donc on traite
par un burlesque par un excès par une
outrance une grande souffrance humaine
donc à partir de là comme il souffre
beaucoup
on a des gags outrancier pseudo violents
ou sans guide en vous comprendrez ce que
je veux dire fable avait complètement si
elle c'est une farce une farce violent
qu'il faut pas y voir des en rage dans
la réalité la lémanique haute que nous
vivons en ce moment si j'avais voulu
faire une dénonciation j'avais fait un
docu drama 16 mm comprenez ça c'est un
vrai film de dénonciation
c'est pas le cas du tout c'est chaplin
dénonce l on pouvait considérer si on
lit chaplin au premier degré on peut on
peut considérer qu'il dix ans tout son
époque aussi pour moi c'est la mauvaise
lecture de chaplin donc vous me direz
les références aux prestigieuses mais
c'est comme un classique donc dans le
dense même andy des scouts à fait
logique
je vous dis y'a pas de dénonciation n'y
a pas de message et simplement la
volonté de traiter un drame par l'humour
voilà donc ça maintenant en même temps
vous infliger aux spectateurs des
spectacles enfin des séquences d'une
violence inouïe on a vu la très
rapidement mais ça va scander tout le
film des coups de pelle
quelle est la signification de cette
violence est est ce qu'on savait faire
rire les gens mais les faire rire sur
quoi exactement monsieur la violence
pour moi elle est surtout présente entre
8h et 8h30 actualité on vit dans un
monde violent alors l'honnêteté est
partie comme on raconte itinéraire de
quelqu'un qui va avoir des pulsions
violentes l'aude était pour moi c'est de
les montrer et aucun voyeurisme
en plus cette violence elle est très
décalé quoi franchement je vous avez vu
les salles je sais pas si les gens
s'amuser mais ces moments là si c'est
très loufoque hills avec des pelles
c'est il ya une vraie loufoquerie dans
cette violence-là par moments la
loufoquerie tire vers le sanguinolent
parce que vous ne l'épargné pas ni les
gros plans avec les visages cabaret
seconde nature et le sens bakool et cdd
l'hyperréalisme la whey lestrem fin pour
moi encore une fois je vous prie de vous
choquer je la trouve très décalé donc me
rappelle une scène des monty python la
quête du graal où ils sont en train de
massacrer ceux pour chevalier noir c'est
extrêmement sanglante c'est donc là
aussi on peut s'arrêter à ça on peut
voir ce qu'il ya derrière non j'ai moi
j'ai pas de lecture du tout violent sur
ce film ça peut ça peut vous paraître
choquant sympa du tout pas du tout ça
sur ces aléas les anecdotique pour moi
les gags est ce qu'elle est burlesque lé
grand guignol surtout parce qu'à chaque
fois il ya des dialogues qui sont là
pour franchement dédramatiser les choses
rien qu'au niveau du son on a mis des
sons cartoon des choses comme ça voila
voila quoi il ya aussi tout au long de
ce film bon un humour ravageur une
désespérance il ya une actrice
absolument formidable qui va devenir à
mon avis une grande révélation
mais il ya aussi à une sorte de deux
conflits quand même de l'individu contre
la société ainsi qu'une analyse des
images veut dire vous parlais tout à
l'heure du journal télévisé mais votre
film
est aussi une réflexion sur les images
images aping de l'actualité images de
gens ce cas c'est quand il se filme lui
l'idée c'était de trouver la voix off
pour montrer le chaos de ce personnage
donc le chaos de ce personnage soit on
fait la voix off et c'est un peu
standards sont montrés lyon indiqué son
journal intime s'était pas vraiment
vraisemblable par rapport à la
psychologie de ses personnages
donc le fait de se filmer par rapport à
quelqu'un qui est en quête d'identité je
trouvais ça très intéressant il image un
peu fruste qui était avec une qualité
kinescoper par la suite renforce l'idée
de chaos du personnage tout ceci par
d'une pure logis scénaristique
il est évident qu'en parlant d'un
personnage qui veut savoir qu'il est gay
névrosée et qui [ __ ] à qui on refuse
son dossier
tout cet itinéraire va nous amener à des
endroits où effectivement on va montrer
des reflets de sociétés qui peuvent
passer pour la dénonciation sociale mais
en tout cas ce n'était pas notre volonté
c'est une bande dessinée ou c'est un
film qui parle d'aujourd'hui nous avons
décidé qu'il parle d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]